let's talk about classical liberalism
over the last couple of years the term
classical liberal has become more and
more popular among a pretty wide variety
of people with varied political beliefs
the term has also become both distorted
in terms of what it actually means and
as a result it sort of started to lose
its meaning and take on a much different
meaning from what it actually means to
be classically liberal many people who
describe themselves as classically
liberal say I believe in individualism
and limited government and free speech
but I also believe in common sense
applications of government this doesn't
mean anything in terms of a political
philosophy it can be interpreted in
endless ways actual classical liberals
think that the government should stay
out of anything whatsoever that the free
market is able to handle this is what
classical liberal thinkers have put
forward so if you call yourself a
classical liberal you're either
referring to libertarianism which is the
actual original meaning of the term and
what the term meant until a few years
ago or you're referring to this vague
vacuous classical liberalism which can
basically mean anything you want it to
mean in which case I would argue what is
the point of even using the term let's
sort it out and remind ourselves first
what classical liberalism actually is
and isn't and evaluate classical
liberalism based on what it actually is
rather than the caricature that's been
created over the last couple of years
once we figure out what classical
liberalism actually is we can then
figure out which aspects make sense and
which might be vapid or even unethical
first of all what is classical
liberalism it's increasingly used in a
vague and incoherent way often by those
who want to profess some degree of
leftism while still separating
themselves from what they see is the
progressive movement or maybe just
elements of it what I found that many
people are mainly trying to get across
when they say that they are classical
liberals is that they oppose so-called
social justice warriors and so-called
regressive leftists and they usually
express this by saying that they are
hardline advocates for free speech but
aside from that many people calling
themselves classical liberals in 2017
are all over the place on many political
issues and attempting to put their
political beliefs in the neat column of
classical liberal probably does more to
confuse than clarify I'm finding the
people who call themselves classical
liberals can be either for economic
regulation or against it
sometimes they're for environmental
regulations sometimes they're against it
some of them want strict immigration
laws some of them don't some are for
universal health care or they're not for
example ben shapiro is someone who is
advocated for quote classical liberal
values he's against state-run universal
health care he's been a huge critic of
welfare yet Carl Benjamin another
self-described classical liberal has
made comments in support of socialized
health care and welfare programs to
other people
GAD sad and sam harris who have
explicitly advocated for or identified
with the term classical liberalism have
totally different political opinions on
many issues two of those four people i
mentioned have supported or at least
been sympathetic to the Donald Trump
movement and two of them have been
extremely critical of Trump so what does
classical liberalism say about a
politician with Donald Trump's views who
knows and by the way none of these
people identify as libertarians yet most
libertarians will tell you that they're
classical liberals and maybe you're
thinking David classical liberalism is
just one attribute of my political
orientation okay but the philosophy of
classical liberalism is being
interpreted in so many different ways
that it's becoming functionally vacuous
and devoid of any objective meaning as
far as actual real world social economic
and foreign policy prescriptions and I'm
mostly critiquing how people use it
as this catch-all neologism to describe
a set of certain political beliefs which
it obviously doesn't and the people who
do say that it's just one piece of how
they identify politically should
understand what it really means which
I'm going to get to in a minute but if
you're wanting to accurately and
specifically describe your political
orientation to people maybe it will
require you to reel off six different
adjectives or actually discuss policy
but that's okay
politics are complicated people's values
are complicated there's rarely one word
or term you can use to appropriately
describe yourself and how you feel about
everything that's going on in the world
for example I find that one label that
most suits me is progressive because I
lean left on most issues civil rights
civil liberties economic regulation
trade the environment health care
whatever but I also criticize
authoritarian leftism because I find
authoritarianism to be particularly not
progressive I've criticized certain
brands of third wave feminism I've
criticized religion including Islam in
situations where I see it fit to be
criticized and I catch flack for that
from certain progressives who often
argue I'm not actually a progressive
another label that reflects some of my
views is Democratic Socialist
I'm also an agnostic I could go on with
other labels but the point is it's a
mixed bag there is no one word that
describes all of my political and
philosophical positions and along these
lines many people are now calling
themselves classical liberals both
without realizing that the term doesn't
even come close to encapsulating their
beliefs but just as importantly without
even really knowing what the term means
I'm especially talking about people who
are left-wing on many economic issues
but they seem to despise so-called sjw's
and they think classical liberal just
means you're Pro free speech and more or
less libertarian in some founding
fathers sort of sense so now that's what
they call themselves
there's also been a trend of some
progressives adopting the classical
liberal label for themselves because the
term progressive has become this sort of
dirty word that's associated with
censorship political correctness violent
protests Islam apologetics etc which
liberal used to be until it was replaced
with progressive five to seven years ago
and I completely understand where those
feelings are coming from but I would
argue that those things aren't truly
progressive I just used the term
progressivism as being interchangeable
with modern liberal values civil
libertarianism and democratic socialism
Bernie Sanders style liberalism not
blowing air horns at seminars and
throwing trash cans through storefront
windows not all progressives and modern
liberals are sjws and authoritarians and
cultural Marxists and progressivism
itself definitely should not be
conflated with those ideas so there's
this sort of fallacious taboo and that's
why many people are starting to call
themselves classical liberals maybe that
doesn't apply to you but it seems like a
common enough thing that I wanted to
address it rather than miss state one's
philosophy is classical liberalism when
the term doesn't really apply real
progressives would be much better off
rescuing the term progressive from all
of that negative baggage that some
people are starting to associate with it
because those things are not progressive
I have plenty of other long-form videos
about that but maybe you truly are a
classical liberal so what does that even
mean classical liberalism means that the
rights of the individual reigned supreme
in large part it's an axiom that assumes
that small government free-market
capitalism and free trade solve most
economic problems a true classical
liberal takes the anti-government
position on many issues economically a
classical liberal is a libertarian or a
conservative basically it's what
Europeans mean when they say liberal
when they're talking about economics in
Europe if you say you're an economic
liberal it means the opposite of what it
means to
most people in the United States it
means you're generally against any
economic regulation classical liberalism
is a fluid concept and there were
classical liberal thinkers of years ago
who did not support full lazy Fair
economics but most of the original
classical liberal economists did believe
in very limited government and
individualism that's sort of what
defines classical liberalism political
terminology does evolve over time and
maybe classical liberalism will come to
mean something else in the future but if
classical liberalism is to mean anything
at all at this point in time the most
efficient way to think about it is to
acknowledge the libertarian and
economically conservative connotations
that have developed around it over the
last half-century so that is our frame
one of the central tenets of classical
liberalism the types of classical
liberalism that today inform right-wing
economic thought is the non-aggression
principle or na P this means anyone can
do whatever they want to do as long as
it doesn't harm other people or prevent
other people from doing what they want
to do under na P aggression is defined
as the initiation of force or coercion
it sounds pretty similar to libertarian
philosophy now under the na P you should
never initiate force or coercion but
it's okay to use force or coercion
against someone that has already
initiated it against you actor a should
not use force against actor B unless
it's to prevent actor B from using force
against them or someone else na P is
inseparable from classical liberalism
here are some quotes from famous
classical liberals talking about na P
John Locke wrote no one ought to harm
another in his life health liberty or
possessions Thomas Jefferson wrote
rightful Liberty is unobstructed action
according to our will within limits
drawn around us by the equal rights of
others I do not add within the limits of
the law because law is often but the
tyrants will and always so
it violates the rights of the individual
Jefferson also wrote no man has a
natural right to commit aggression on
the equal rights of another and this is
all from which the laws ought to
restrain him
Herbert Spencer wrote every man is free
to do that which he wills provided he
infringes not the equal freedom of any
other man John Stuart Mill wrote the
only purpose for which power can be
rightfully exercised over any member of
a civilized community against his will
is to prevent harm to others Murray
Rothbard wrote no one may threaten or
commit violence against another man's
person or property violence may be
employed only against the man who
commits such violence that is only
defensively against the aggressive
violence of another in short no violence
may be employed against a non aggressor
don't get me wrong I think that people
like John Locke and Thomas Jefferson
were important thinkers crucial to the
Enlightenment obviously mankind is
indebted to the Enlightenment it was the
modern birth of things like separation
of church and state separation of powers
and government the scientific method the
list goes on the relevant point for us
here is that classical liberalism and
the people who have shaped classical
liberalism are inherently connected to
the non-aggression principle
libertarians and people who are
economically on the right will
constantly confirm this
so the non-aggression principle sounds
great right I mean leave other people
alone unless they're bothering you or
someone else but let's dig into it more
first off even just the idea of
non-aggression is a completely unstable
ethical construct because there are so
many definitions of force and coercion
and different interpretations of
initiation there's not one definition of
force and coercion and it's difficult to
nail down sometimes who exactly is the
first initiating it therefore n AP can
be used in almost any which way somebody
wants in order to fit their agenda for
example a classical liberal adhering to
n ap might say taxing people's incomes
is an act of unprovoked aggression
but they might at the same time say it's
not an act of aggression for huge
companies to merge and create monopolies
damaging to the average citizen this is
a popular libertarian principle and you
can't make a distinction between these
two examples using the principle of
volunteerism because neither the person
being taxed nor the victims of the
monopolies are consenting to the force
that's used against them here's another
issue with n AP what is an appropriate
type and amount of force to use against
someone who's using force against you or
somebody else let's say you're walking
on the sidewalk and somebody out of
nowhere starts shoving you they've
committed an act of initiating
aggression towards you unprovoked force
according to n AP it's okay for you to
respond with force but what kind of
force should you use in response and how
much and for how long did you shove them
back can you steal their phone would you
be allowed to shoot them do you slap
them in the face every day for a year so
you might say oh but David that's
ridiculous you should only respond with
force that's proportionate to the force
initiated against you and only just
enough to prevent them from using force
against you in perpetuity or again
common sense might tell us that but n ap
doesn't answer those questions it just
says don't be the first to initiate
force you can only answer these
questions by also invoking other
principles that are subjective or
collectivist a subjective solution would
be hey I don't like that here's what I
think an appropriate response is or a
collectivist solution would be let's say
a system of laws regarding assault and
self-defense and this non-aggression
principle is what gives us right-wing
small government or libertarian
economics classical liberal economics
government intervention in the economy
violates n ap according to the people
who believe in and care about the
construct of the non-aggression
principle another principle of classical
liberalism is to have a government that
protects individualism and provide
services that the free market cannot
provide the strict classical liberal
perspective on health care is a
free-market
for profit system since the free market
can provide that just inefficiently as
we can see in the US when you compare
our healthcare system to that of other
developed countries so if you say I'm a
leftist but more of a classical liberal
than a progressive you're signing on to
a really right-wing view of health care
if you follow the doctrine just being
for free speech and against sjw's
doesn't really make you a classical
liberal if you believe that the
government does have a role to play in
making sure businesses are for example
considering the public interest genuine
pure classical liberal free-market
economics
breeds inequality under which monopolies
are inevitable which are
uncontroversially detrimental to
economies and societies the wealthy can
pay for better education which also
breeds more inequality you have an
overabundance of negative externalities
like pollution which leads to a lower
quality of life for everyone but
especially for the poor without the
government regulating and disseminating
information about food and drugs were
left at the mercy of the companies
distributing those products completely
free markets have erratic boom and bust
cycles making them completely unstable
and ultimately unsustainable the civil
libertarian ideals of classical
liberalism are valuable and inform
progressivism which is to say modern
evolved liberalism social democracy
democratic socialism but the ultimate
full realization of classical
libertarianism is totally dystopic if
you follow the ideology to its logical
end and implement a pure unadulterated
form of libertarianism classical
liberalism and the non-aggression
principle that's what you get when those
ideas are followed to their natural
conclusions an economy run by little
government a society where all that
matters is the individual with no regard
for the collective that's what classical
liberalism is a value system where
individualism and economic
non-interventionism is held above other
values
and if that's not what you want for the
world then you're not totally committed
to the ideology of classical liberalism
if classical liberalism can even mean
anything at all this is the goal of any
classical liberal with the courage of
their convictions a world where economic
interactions are almost completely free
of intervention by government or other
socialist collectivist systems otherwise
you're not really fully and honestly
extrapolating the implications of your
so-called classical liberalism in any
sense of the term that can be
operationally meaningful today if you're
not a small government capitalist
economic right-winger you might not be a
classical liberal you might be some sort
of variation but for the sake of clarity
maybe you'll consider that the term
classical liberal is not the catch-all
label for your values if you truly are a
classical liberal as actually defined I
personally don't believe that you're
advocating for the economic well-being
of our society